joining us now is 60 Minutes
correspondent John Wortham he was a
longtime colleague of Grant walls at
Sports Illustrated John good morning to
you I can't imagine John how you're
feeling when I heard first heard the
news it's one of those things you can't
believe what you're reading number one
but my first thought of course was for
Celine this news is still so jarring I
can't imagine what it's like for people
who actually knew him and worked with
him so how are you processing this
yeah it's it's a process I mean it's
it's just it's it's every cliche Rings
true it feels surreal I sort of woke up
to this and thought I'd gotten a lot of
texts from Grant and I realized they
weren't taxed they were there were news
alerts it's been a great source of
comfort that what we always knew that
this was a prince of a human being
someone with great impact with great
compassion it's it's been a real comfort
that uh the world seems to recognize
this and he's he's getting these these
tributes that are so well deserved
he's 49 uh he was healthy his brother
has gone on social media and is Raising
questions about the cause of death he's
raising the possibility of Foul Play
does any of that ring true to you I
think it's still very early in the game
to make any kind of determination about
that
yeah I would agree with that and I think
you know Eric Brett's brother
um was in an emotional place that he's
written about subsequent and I think you
know if Grant stood for one thing it was
reporting facts and thoroughness and I I
think sort of in the spirit of Grant's
approach to the job into media
um you know the speculations would
probably uh take take a back seat until
we know more but I mean the whole set of
circumstances the whole fact pattern the
fact that this was at a World Cup
um it's just it's it's really still a
few days later still jarring John it's
awful to be talking about the legacy of
someone who is just 49 years old and
it's so much life ahead of them but when
you look back at his work not only uh
coverage of soccer but LeBron James
cover uh famous one back in 2003 for
Sports Illustrated uh talk to me a bit
about there it is on your screen there
uh the chosen one uh talk to me a bit
about uh his journalism of soccer but
also his wider work of the sports world
yeah I mean it's funny people forget we
talk about him as this preeminent soccer
reporter and writer and people forget in
2002 he introduces teenager from from
Akron to uh to millions of people but no
I mean I think I think some of Grant's
Legacy will obviously be the output the
work even in that that excellent piece
you guys did Tony you can see he works
in a variety of mediums and video and
podcasting obviously in writing but I
think apart from the the output I I
think it's also about the the process
sort of actions as well as words and the
way he went about his job the way he
mentored the way he was so thorough the
way he avoided easy click bait and hot
takes I I think a lot of his legacy will
be the product that will live on and
people will be reading about and
listening to but I also think um we
would do well to consider the way he
went about committing these acts of
Journalism the way he went about the uh
the process
you know we will also be thinking a lot
about his family in the days ahead John
worthon thank you for helping us
remember we appreciate it